Quinta how was your weekend Quinta hey
hey hey Quinta I'm heaven uh-huh so how
was your weekend hey girl I love you in
your haircut you get your hair cut or is
it a weave you guys kind of a lace front
right is it is it a lace panel oh this
coat rack is such a mess look at this so
ratchet
can I touch it oh no
[Music]
I think Obama's doing great and I'm not
saying you're here because of
affirmative action or anything so Martin
Luther King Day is coming up you got
anything planned do I maintain plan for
the office I've seen all five seasons in
three seasons of the wire and why would
you think that I was the one planning
them I just assumed it because you are
hey you crazy
you see pointer room are you guys go to
that company banquet down at the
Richardson plantation it's at a
plantation I'm not racist
she's been a bad day I forgot my glasses
at home we could no fights
wait Quinta we're gonna grab some
chicken well it's no if you want some
hey heaven a question for you chicken
because I'm black for is he just being
considerate been chasing for a while I'm
gonna have you everything but if I do
want some chicken
do I look like a stereotype piano just
want some lunch I just have to be so
hard
aren't you so excited yeah yeah oh go
get a hamburger which is basically I
want you to know that like I respect you
Tracy I am so sorry about the Martin
Luther King pain I am the worst I'm
heaven kind of it of course you're heavy
enough so I don't get mad at people try
to touch my hair
[Music]